[APPLAUSE]
E. FOLEY: I am E. Foley.
B. COATES: And I'm B. Coates.
But we are also, as
you said, Liz and Beth.
E. FOLEY: And we're here to talk
about "What Would Boudicca Do,
Everyday Problems
Solved by History's Most
Remarkable Women."
B. COATES: It's been
a really amazing year
for the sort of the
amplification of women's
voices, particularly in the
UK with this centenary year
of women's suffrage.
E. FOLEY: And also
as part of that
there has been lots
of raising awareness
of the achievements
of women from history
that have perhaps
in the past been
kind of let slide a little bit.
And we very much
endorse the theory
if you can see it you can be it.
And so our book is
designed kind of
to help women deal with problems
that might come up today,
even though the women themselves
are actually from times far
back in the past.
We have chapters on women
from different cultures,
from different
backgrounds, covering
lots of different disciplines.
So we have sportswomen,
women involved in science,
in literature, in piracy.
B. COATES: We know it's a
really noisy conversation,
this conversation
about women right now,
but we want to take the
stories one step further
and see if they could actually
help us in our daily lives.
E. FOLEY: So the way
our book's organized
is it's divided into
50 short chapters,
and each chapter focuses
one particular high achiever
from the past, and
each of them answers
a very specific problem.
Some of those problems are
serious, and some of them
we're being slightly
more lighthearted with.
So we have Mae West
on body positivity,
we have Emily Dickinson
on defying FOMO,
we have Grace Hopper on
facing up to failure.
B. COATES: And Grainne
O'Malley who is our pirate
is on work life balance.
But we're obviously here in
the middle of a working day,
so we wanted to look at
certain women who might help us
in certain dilemmas that might
come up in the working office
life.
E. FOLEY: So we
start with someone
who is very famous for
being very good at her job.
B. COATES: So Elizabeth I is
somebody that I channel daily,
and particularly at this
exact moment in time,
because we're talking about her
in relation to public speaking.
OK.
So dry mouth.
E. FOLEY: Yep.
B. COATES: Sweaty palms.
B. COATES: Voice all
weird, squeaky and high?
E. FOLEY: Really trying
to counteract that.
B. COATES: Well, most of
us approach public speaking
with a rising sense of dread.
It's true.
But if we can learn
to fight the fear,
the rewards are very rich.
And also it's worth just noting
that pretty much all of us
are going to have to do it at
some stage during our lives.
Elizabeth I had a very
tricky start in life.
She was a toddler when she
was banished from court
by her father,
Henry VIII, who also
accused her mother
Anne Boleyn of adultery
and had her beheaded.
E. FOLEY: Just kind of
excellent dad skills
to start you off with.
B. COATES: But nevertheless
she became queen in 1558
after her sister died.
She inherited a country
that was completely
divided by religious conflict.
So her first job was to
reinstate Protestantism.
And she had to use
all of her sort
of persuasive
interpersonal skills,
and a very stage managed
sense of authority
to achieve what she achieved.
So within one year she'd
got rid of the pope
as the head of the
Church of England,
installing herself,
naturally, in that place.
She'd re-established the
Church of England as well,
and she basically had
taken the decision
not to force her subjects into
religious conformity, which
is what her sister had done.
E. FOLEY: So Mary before her had
done that with a lot of burning
and murder involved.
And Elizabeth was clearly
hoping to end up with a better
epithet than Bloody.
B. COATES: Bloody Mary
is what she was called.
And so Elizabeth
was wildly clever.
We know this.
She was fluent in French,
Greek, Italian, Latin.
She enjoyed translating the
classics in her spare time.
She composed sonnets as
well, in her free time.
Basically she was a
massive overachiever.
But even for
someone like her, it
must have been pretty tough
to walk into parliament
and express herself in a room
full of much more politically
savvy men.
And I think what she was
really good at was putting
on a sort of imperial show.
And this is another
thing that she sort of
harnessed in her working
life, which we can do.
One of her sort of
big hobbies was drama.
So under her there was this
great flowering of sort
of English
literature, and drama.
Of course Shakespeare
and Spencer,
but also people like Thomas
Kidd and Christopher Marlowe
as well.
E. FOLEY: Yeah.
And that's actually
something that
comes up in lots of
kind of modern guides
to public speaking, is that
watching actors perform
is a really good way of
honing presentation skills.
So she was doing that
all the way back.
B. COATES: Yeah.
So obviously her
private life was
a matter of great
public interest,
and she had many suitors,
and obviously she
was known as the Virgin Queen.
And at one point parliament
got incredibly jumpy
about the succession
of the throne,
and they threatened to take
away her allowance, essentially.
So she used her sort
of rhetorical moxie
in that instance, and she made
one of her great speeches,
and her best cross voice, and
she said at present it is not
convenient, nor never shall
be without some peril unto
you and certain danger unto me.
So she was brilliant at
holding off parliament and also
suitors, but she was also good
at holding off her threats
from abroad, most famously
against the Spanish Armada
in 1588.
She appeared-- there was
this brilliant moment where
she appeared with the troops
at Tilbury in full regalia.
She had this real
genius for grandstanding
and swashbuckling.
E. FOLEY: And she
actually, she turned up
in a long white velvet gown
with armor on a gray horse
to make her red hair
look particularly good.
And what she was doing
there was very visibly
channeling Boudicca
from the past.
And we talk a bit
about Boudicca later.
B. COATES: Yeah.
So Elizabeth was like
the ultimate kind
of motivational speaker.
She placed herself with
her troops to G them up.
And the speech was amazing.
So she uses this great language.
She says, I know I
have but the body
of a weak and
feeble woman, but I
have the heart and stomach of
a king, and a king of England,
too.
Which is a sort of brilliant
humble brag in some ways.
She's sort of acknowledging
what the troops might've
been thinking, like are
we being led by a woman.
But at the same time, in
the next sentence completely
subverting it, saying,
I am your leader.
She also knew when to deliver
a bit of emotional sweet talk
in a public way.
Her final farewell to parliament
is known as the golden speech,
and it basically made them all
cry, which we think is a great
send off.
We're not going
to do that today.
She said to them, though you
have had many princes more
white mighty and wise
sitting in this seat,
yet you have never had any
more careful and loving.
So we think maybe
the next time we're
trying to do a tricky
presentation to our line
managers, we can
remember the tough crowd
that Elizabeth was facing.
For her, her reign was
known as the Golden Age.
I mean, that might be
too much to pull off
as your tenure in the
accounts department,
but hey, it's a good
thing to aim at.
And finally we have some tips.
E. FOLEY: From Elizabeth.
So first thing is think
about presentation.
Obviously wear white velvet
at all opportunities.
B. COATES: Alcohol in
small doses does no harm.
And also remember
that worse things do
happen at sea,
particularly, obviously,
if you are the Spanish Armada.
And most of the time,
99% of people watching
are willing you to smash it.
Or they're just thinking about
their dinner, so either way.
It's not something--
E. FOLEY: We're fine either way.
B. COATES: Exactly.
E. FOLEY: So the next person
we wanted to talk about
is someone who was also very
good at putting on a good show,
and this is 1930s
screen siren Hedy
Lamarr, who was known in her
day as the most beautiful woman
in the world.
And she was so beautiful that
people found it quite difficult
to believe that there was
anything much going on
behind her gorgeous green eyes.
We talk about her and
knowing your worth,
because we love Hedy.
She pursued her work passions
in the face of much naysaying
and resistance.
And she was an actress, both
an actress and an inventor,
and the inventor
part of her life
has had a lot more
coverage recently,
and she's been celebrated
for that more, although still
with a lingering
sense of surprise
that someone who
looks so good could
be so clever, particularly
if they're a woman.
B. COATES: Because
we all know women
are rubbish at science, as
well as fighting, parking,
and barbecues.
E. FOLEY: So Hedy he was
born in 1913 in Austria,
and she grew up in a cultivated
and comfortable home,
and she went to drama
school in Berlin,
and after that she got
her first big break.
And it was sort of like a high
brow version of the Kardashian
sex tape, because she was
involved in a Czech film called
"Ecstasy," which was the
first widely released film
to have an explicit
sex scene in it.
Which it was banned in the US,
it was denounced by the pope,
her parents went to the premiere
and had a very uncomfortable
time.
It's very sweet, actually,
by modern standards,
although Hedy does run
around starkers in it.
And there is a famous scene
where she's acting out
the sexual ecstasy of the title,
which apparently was achieved
by the director poking her
bum with a pin in order
to get the desired effect,
which is quite a disturbing way
to deal with a
teenage colleague,
but it did launch her on
her celebrity career path.
B. COATES: She had
something really interesting
to say about that career
path, where she defined it
as, she said, the ladder
of success in Hollywood
is usually a press agent,
actor, director, producer,
leading man, and
you're a star if you
sleep with each one of
them in that order, which
is kind of extraordinary
that she was saying that
50 years ago and feels very
depressingly familiar to us.
E. FOLEY: Yes.
Hedy's new found star light
was quite quickly snuffed out
by her possessive husband.
He was a wealthy
fascist arms dealer,
and he was not keen on people
watching his wife in this film.
So he rounded up all of
the prints to destroy them.
And Hedy soon tired of
his controlling ways,
and she legged it,
one night, apparently,
according to her story,
dressed as a maid.
She snuck out of their castle
and ran away to London.
And whatever the
truth of that, it
is a good feisty
background story
to give herself to
make herself stand out
against the other kind
of wannabe starlets
that she was up
against at that point.
B. COATES: She
was really good, I
think, like Elizabeth I at
using storytelling and building
a narrative to make
you stand out, exactly.
E. FOLEY: By 1938 she was cast
in her first English language
film, and from that point
on she found herself mainly
cast in seductive, exotic kind
of roles, which she became
a bit bored with
to the point where
she started her own company
so she could avoid it.
But in 1949 she went
back into the kind
of low cut gowns for Cecil B.
DeMille's "Samson and Delilah,"
which was an enormous hit.
B. COATES: Yeah, it was a film--
so Groucho Marx said about it,
I'm not interested in a film
where the man's tits are bigger
than the woman's, which is kind
of, again, a bit depressing
thing to say about
the women's role
on the silver screen in the
golden age of Hollywood.
E. FOLEY: And Hedy was
certainly not just T&A. She
had a singular brain
inside her head,
and when World War
II came, she was
very keen to be involved
in the war effort.
And she had, while living
with her ex-husband,
she'd picked up quite a lot
of knowledge about armaments.
B. COATES: So
essentially whenever
the Third Reich
came to dinner, she
was there just having a
good old listen to what they
were talking about.
E. FOLEY: And she teamed up
with a pianist called George
Antheil, and together they
developed a frequency hopping
radio device to
help missiles get
through German defenses,
which they donated to the Navy
for free, the patent
for free, but it was not
exploited at that time.
But I think as most
people know now,
that technology has become part
of Wi-Fi and GPS and things
that we use all the time now.
And Hedy really loved
inventing things.
It was like her
proper top hobby.
She applied to the
National Inventors Council,
but they rebuffed her.
But she used to when she was on
film sets sit and tinker away.
She invented new designs
for traffic signals,
a fluorescent dog collar, a
tissue box, and also an idea
for a powdered fizzy
drinks cube that you
could drop into your water
to make yourself Coke.
But people were
much more interested
in her six marriages and her
later scandalous behavior,
which included lawsuits and
extreme plastic surgery,
and her kind of eccentric
hobby didn't really
fit with the marketing of her as
a kind of Hollywood sex symbol.
And so it was not
until she was 84
that she was recognized
as an inventor,
and that's when
she and George were
given pioneer awards from the
Electronic Frontier Foundation
B. COATES: And she said
brilliantly, well it's
about time.
[LAUGHTER]
E. FOLEY: No one could
rock a center parting,
a bold lipstick, and an
elegant understanding of spread
spectrum broadcasts like Hedy.
Thank you.
But the important thing we
felt we learned from her story
was to follow our
own interests, even
if others can't see the point.
She was brilliantly
clear on where
she attributed her own value.
So she was very proud
of being an inventor.
But she famously said of the
glitzy bit of her career,
any girl can be glamorous.
All you have to do is stand
still and look stupid.
B. COATES: So next
up we have Odette.
So Hedy's involvement in the
war was undoubtedly patriotic,
but it was kind
of at a distance.
We have some women in our
book whose involvement in war
was really visceral,
very close up,
and Odette's one
of the first ones.
We talk about her in terms
of being open to experience
and not being afraid
of our mistake.
So the parallel we
make in the book
is that feeling when
you press reply,
you think you've pressed
reply and you've actually
pressed reply all
and you've sent
something about your
colleague to the whole floor.
Well, for Odette, she made
a kind of mistake like that.
And it changed her life
kind of completely.
What we wanted to
think about was
instead of when you send
that email locking yourself
in the loo and
thinking, oh my God,
if you could think of a
way to keep your chin up
and be brave and try and
learn from your mistakes
rather than be
completely cowed by them.
Yeah, for her it
had life changing,
amazing repercussions.
E. FOLEY: Which is
good news for all of us
who make that mistake
on a regular basis.
B. COATES: So she was
born in 1912 in France,
and her father had been a
decorated hero in World War
I. He was killed in World
War I, and every Sunday
her grandfather took
her to his grave
and said if war comes
again, it's your duty
to do what your father did.
E. FOLEY: Which I think today's
child psychologists would
have a field day with that.
But Odette was made
of stern stuff.
B. COATES: She was.
So then she married a British
guy and she moved to London,
and then when the Second World
War broke out her husband
enlisted, and then
the Battle of Britain
and the blitz kind
of reduced London
to a real proper war zone.
So she moved to Somerset
with her mother-in-law
and by now three small children.
E. FOLEY: So again, stern
stuff to go and live
with your mother-in-law
and three small children.
B. COATES: Yes, absolutely.
And she was in Somerset when
she heard a BBC broadcast asking
for holiday photographs
from northern France,
because the Luftwaffe
controlled French airspace,
and the Brits were trying
to figure out a way
to map their bombing raids.
So she sent this
letter saying that she
knew the area like
the back of her hand,
but she misaddressed it.
She sent it not to
the admiralty which
is where it should have gone,
but she sent it to the Navy,
and they then passed it on to
the Army, who then passed it
to the SOE, the Special
Operations Executive.
And they immediately
thought this woman
would make an amazing spy.
But what they were worried
about is she was a woman.
She had three small children.
How would she cope if she
was captured and tortured?
Again, you know,
they couldn't know
that she would prove
to be as hard as nails.
E. FOLEY: And in fact that
three small children can
prepare you to resist torture.
B. COATES: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
E. FOLEY: We both have
three small children.
B. COATES: So
Odette did agonize,
but eventually
her sort of horror
of what was going on in her
beloved home country won out,
so she began training and she
learned all the good stuff--
Morse code, how to
handle firearms,
self-defense, resisting
interrogation.
E. FOLEY: And her final
report was glowing,
but it did note a complete
unwillingness to admit that she
could ever be wrong, which
is a strategy that is worth
bearing in mind if you ever
are dealing with the fallout
from emailing an error.
B. COATES: Yes.
So Odette was now
Agent S23, and she
was dropped into
northern France to work
for a man called Peter
Churchill in a resistance group.
Very quickly they were betrayed
by somebody inside the group,
and she was handed
over to the Germans.
And they got very confused by
this Peter Churchill situation.
They thought he was a
relative of Winston Churchill,
and Odette was very happy
to go along with that.
They tortured her horribly.
There are descriptions
of what happened to her.
She had her toenails ripped out.
She was burnt on her
back with hot irons,
but she stood completely
firm and didn't squeal.
So eventually the
Germans sent her
to Ravensbrook
concentration camp.
And the commandant there,
again, had heard this story
about Peter Churchill,
who she claimed
they were in a
relationship, and the fact
that he was Winston's
relative, so he thought
he had kind of hostage
gold on his hands,
and when the Allied
forces were closing in,
he took Odette in
his car with the plan
to hand her over as
a bargaining chip,
essentially, to the Americans.
E. FOLEY: That turned out to be
a bad plan from the commandant,
because Odette
immediately daubed him in,
and she stole
documents from his car
and she then later
testified against him.
B. COATES: And so amazingly
Peter Churchill also
survived the war, and when
they came back to London,
Odette divorced her
husband and married Peter.
So she did get her Mr.
Churchill in the end.
She was awarded an MBE, and
she was the first person
to be awarded the George
Cross for gallantry.
She died in 1995 at
the ripe old age of 82,
and she's just this brilliant
icon of bravery and resistance
and all round hard
as nails womanhood,
and all because of a mistake.
So I think the lesson
we took from her
is that if something
goes wrong for you,
think about your reaction.
It's also the ability
to deal with a situation
when there's a massive cock
up, which kind of makes
us potentially
better human beings.
And actually aiming for
constant perfection probably
leads to massive unhappiness.
E. FOLEY: So we move
from one warrior
woman to another, our
title lady, many centuries
before Odette.
So what happens if the
pursuit of your passion,
like Hedy, and your
openness to opportunity,
like Odette, leads you
into conflict with others?
So women in particular
suffer cultural pressure
to be agreeable at all times.
And we talk in our
book about how lucky
we are to have had women
like Rosalind Franklin,
like Cleopatra or Coco
Chanel, difficult women
as they were called,
forging an alternative path.
But this pressure
does still remain.
And our next subject is Boudicca
on sticking up for yourself.
B. COATES: So she's
Norfolk's best known queen.
She's a woman from
history who totally
stepped outside of the lane of
what was expected of a lady.
Her reputation rests
on her unusual levels
of assertiveness, or what
you might call bloodthirsty
revenge-fueled aggression.
Anyway.
E. FOLEY: So Boudicca's
story's full of holes
and legendary embellishments,
but it's generally
agreed that she was the chief of
the Iceni tribe in East Anglia
about 2,000 years ago.
After the Romans
invaded Britain,
they made an agreement
with her husband
that he would be
able to continue
to govern his own
people, very generously.
But when he died, that
gentleman's agreement
did not extend to the ladies,
and they immediately took
Boudicca's land, and
not content with just
that, they also publicly flogged
her and raped her children.
So this is all according
to their historian Tacitus.
He's the best
source that we have
for what Boudicca then did.
So instead of being
cowed by this,
or accepting the inevitable
sexual violence that
comes to women in
situations of conflict,
Boudicca set the world on fire.
She led a full on
revolt, and she
burnt the cities of Colchester,
St. Albans, and London
to the ground, killing almost
all the inhabitants, both Roman
and Britain, and
she almost managed
to wipe the Ninth Legion off
the face of the earth, as well.
B. COATES: There's that
brilliant fact, isn't there,
that apparently she
literally left her mark.
So if you dig down
there's a layer
of red sediment, which
is from her burning.
Yeah.
E. FOLEY: So she's the first
in a line of female rulers
that we talk about
in the book, which
include Cleopatra, Elizabeth
I, and Catherine the Great.
And they were
celebrated as anomalies,
because it was so
unusual for women
to be in positions of power.
And Tacitus, as I said, the
most reliable source about her,
was really obsessed with
how weird it was that there
was a woman leading an army.
He elsewhere talks
about all the shrieking
that there was
because women were
allowed on the
battlefields in Britain,
and this horrified him.
But the Romans were
particularly sensitive to this,
because they didn't think
that women were logical enough
to handle high stress
leadership roles,
and they were very sensitized
to this by Cleopatra.
Everything that happened with
her kind of sex and death thing
had really freaked them out.
But Tacitus was
himself grudgingly
impressed with how Boudicca
dealt with what he acknowledged
was extreme dishonor.
B. COATES: Yeah.
I mean so, obviously, the
offenses against Boudicca
are much more
serious than anything
we might come up against in
our normal working lives,
and murder and mutilation are
definitely not the response
to any everyday problem.
E. FOLEY: But we saw something
in her emphatic response
that we thought was
inspiring, albeit with less
disemboweling and mutilation.
Sometimes extreme
disrespect does
warrant a noisy counterattack.
But Boudicca nurtured
a very literal
take no prisoners attitude.
But I think she can act as
a source of encouragement
for those of us who struggle
with expressing dissent.
She wasn't worried
about making enemies.
about causing a scene.
She was confident in
her own authority,
and that meant that other
tribes rallied around her
when she started her rebellion.
We can't claim she
had a happy ending.
The Romans turned out to
be pretty good at fighting.
B. COATES: As well
as construction,
aqueducts, the legal system.
E. FOLEY: Under floor heating.
B. COATES: That's right.
E. FOLEY: But the Roman
emperor did actually
rethink his policy
for colonizing Britain
and go with a less aggressive
kind of stance on it
after her revolt, because it
was so significant to them.
She died by suicide,
Boudicca, to avoid capture.
And to add insult
to injury, her name
has been misspelled for quite
a long time as Boudicea,
and that is apparently
due to a kind of typo
essentially in one of
Tacitus's manuscripts
being copied when they
were copied by one person
to another.
And legend has it she's buried
between platforms nine and 10
at King's Cross Station.
So she's apparently
very near here.
The ambiguities
in her story mean
that she's been
repurposed as a symbol
for many different causes.
We don't know whether she
was pro or anti empire,
we don't know whether her
concerns were primarily
political or domestic.
Was she a war hero?
Was she a war criminal?
What would she
think about Brexit?
Her reputation lives on because
the UK loves an underdog,
and also because
she categorically
refused to be swept aside by
the more powerful forces that
were in play at her time.
So sometimes it's the nice thing
to do to be nice and back down.
But sometimes it's important
to fight for what you believe.
B. COATES: Absolutely.
So next up is Sappho, who is
another figure whose reputation
sustains despite the best
efforts of history to erase it.
Sappho is someone else who went
her own way, and in our book,
we talk about her
and backing yourself.
So when it comes
to criticism, we
believe there's no one
nastier than ourselves.
It's very easy to
beat yourself up
when the meeting doesn't go
to plan or a deal doesn't come
off, but instead of sort
of throwing ourselves
down a well of self-hate,
what if there was another way?
And how do we go about shushing
that belittling inner voice?
We think Sappho has something
to tell us about accepting
ourselves, warts and all.
She was a literary smash in her
own time, an ancient Greek poet
who had nine volumes of her
work at the very famous library
of Alexandria, and
the librarians there
named her as the only
woman in their roster
of nine prime poets.
E. FOLEY: And even Plato who
was not a big fan of poetry
called her the 10th muse.
B. COATES: But by the Middle
Ages, almost everything of hers
had disappeared.
It's partly to do with
the ravages of time.
So that library of Alexandria
suffered a huge fire
in which all sorts of original
documentation was lost.
And it's partly to
do with the fact
that she wrote in a very
particular dialect, which
by the Middle Ages had died out.
But blame also has to
lie at the feet of some
of the clergymen
of the Middle Ages,
who were totally freaked by
the joyous sexuality that's
right there in her poems.
E. FOLEY: One of them called
her a sex crazed whore
who sings of her own
wantonness, which is not
what you see on the back
of the Penguin Classics
edition [INAUDIBLE].
B. COATES: In the last two
decades, fragments of her poems
have been rediscovered, and
they revealed whole sections
of Sappho's rhymes.
It's very interesting
that people immediately
knew that this was
Sappho, because she had
invented the Sapphic stanza.
E. FOLEY: And you have to be
pretty confident in yourself
to feel that you need to invent
a new poetic form to express
your genius.
B. COATES: So all
aspects of her life
have been the subject
of feverish speculation
over the years.
The truth is we don't
know very much about her.
We don't know what
her sexuality was,
we don't know who
her family were,
but we do know is
that she is associated
with the liberal
island of Lesbos,
but because attitudes to
homosexuality in ancient times
are so different to how we
might consider them now,
it's very difficult to say
if she was a lesbian or not.
Ovid, who is a Roman poet
about 500 years later,
came up with the
theory that she ran
kind of romantic
finishing schools
for girls, that she was
teaching them the art of love
through her poems.
But what's amazing
is even though we
know nothing, what we
do have are these poems
and what sort of sings out
to us across the millennias,
this incredible voice
and her sort of feelings
about love and romance.
And there's a very famous
slightly uninspiringly titled
poem called "Fragment
31," and the set
up is she's watching on
jealously as some man flirts
with this beautiful girl.
And she talks about-- it's
just an incredible articulation
of desire and jealousy.
She talks about her sweating
palms and her ears thrumming,
her blood kind of
pulsing in her veins.
And what's amazing
is that she's really
in touch with her
feelings about love.
There's no fear of that
emotional vulnerability.
She sort of owns her weaknesses
and her fallibilities.
E. FOLEY: And she does the
same in another poem where
she talks about
aging, and she talks
about her kind of knackered
knees and her sagging skin,
and that's not something that
she feels she needs to hide.
B. COATES: Exactly.
So we've got some rules
about backing yourself.
First of all, it's good to
remember that nobody's perfect.
In fact, imperfection is a trait
shared by all the very best
people through history.
We're bound to come up against
other people's judgment,
just as Sappho's work
did, but you should
try to stand strong on that.
And remember, it
doesn't matter what
you look like as long as your
soul is in really good shape.
So Sappho had a great line
that says a handsome man guards
his image a while.
A good man will one
day take on beauty.
E. FOLEY: So we're pitching
our book as kind of inspiring
and hoping that it fills readers
with kind of vim and vigor
to take on the issues
of the modern world
with these great role
models, but it did also
strike us that a book
of 50 really high
achieving women who changed
the world might actually
make us feel a bit inadequate,
and our next heroine
is actually someone who makes
me feel quite inadequate.
So she is the 18th
century interpreter
and explorer Sacagawea.
And there's no way that
I could do what she did,
which was travel
thousands of miles
through uncharted territory
with a new baby strapped
to her back the whole time.
And I really hate camping.
So that is clearly out
of my comfort zone.
But we do think there's
also a broader message
to be taken from her life.
So Sacagawea was born--
she's a Native American
from the Shoshone tribe,
and she was born
around 1788, and she
was the daughter
of a chief, but she
was kidnapped when she was very
young by an enemy tribe called
the Hidatsa, and
they sold her to be
essentially the extra wife of
a French Canadian trapper, who
was the melodious named
Toussaint Charbonneau, who
had the incommodious reputation
of being a right stinker.
He was described in
reports of the time
as a man of no particular
merit, and apparently
an attempted rapist.
But of course we have no records
of what Sacagawea thought
of being married to this guy.
In 1804, the US
president decided
that he wanted a
military expedition
to explore the uncolonized
west of the continent,
and the leaders
of that expedition
arrived in Sacagawea's village.
And they had the grandiose
name the Corps of Discovery.
B. COATES: I always think that's
funny, the Corps of Discovery.
They're basically
missing the fact
that it was not an
undiscovered land for all
of the native people there.
E. FOLEY: People
already lived there.
The corps was led by Captain
Lewis and Lieutenant Clark,
and they were keen to find
interpreters to help them
on their journey, particularly
as they were going up
the Missouri River into
potentially deadly territory.
And Charbonneau and
Sacagawea between them
could speak French,
Hidatsa, and Shoshone,
and so they were employed
by Lewis and Clark
even though at that point
Sacagawea was heavily pregnant
with her first child.
And in fact the expedition
set off just two months
after she had had her baby.
So she had a little boy,
Jean Baptiste, and then
she strapped him to her back.
She was 17 years old.
She set off on an all-male
expedition, about 60 men
and just her, carrying
him on her back,
traveling all the way to
the Pacific, mainly by boat.
And it was her survival skills
and her geographical knowledge
which contributed a
lot to that expedition.
B. COATES: And there's that
famous story, isn't there,
where she had to jump in, and
her husband capsized the canoe
at one point, she had to jump
in and rescue their supplies.
E. FOLEY: So it was a
really tough journey.
They were kind of
beset by illness.
There was the threat of
attack from hostile locals.
There were grizzly bears.
One man did actually die.
But Sacagawea made it all
the way to the Pacific
and then all the way back again.
This expedition helped
the mapping of the West
and the eventual expansion
of the United States,
and she was a key
player in that.
So sometimes the
constant recalibration
of work life balance
can feel impossible,
but I think Sacagawea's story
puts this into perspective.
Most of us these days
don't get kidnapped,
get to choose who we marry,
get to choose whether or not
we want to try and have
kids as a starting point.
And traveling thousands of
miles with a two-month-old
on your back certainly
puts the school
run into perspective for us.
It's hard to find
a better example
of an unstoppable heroine to
kind of pep up your spirits
and make you feel like
anything is possible.
B. COATES: Absolutely.
OK, so our next case our next
heroine is in Enheduanna,
you we talk about
her and creativity.
So obviously we're
here in Google.
We don't need to tell you
anything about creativity.
But what if meetings
and WhatsApp groups
and the kind of constant
deluge of millions of emails
is crushing it,
and you can't find
the time for your
creative juices to flow.
Well we know that feeding
your inner imagineer
leads to huge rewards.
Your jobs are better, you
can ease your relationship
tensions, it can make you
genuinely feel more alive
and fulfilled.
And Enheduanna is an ancient
Mesopotamian priestess
who took it a step further.
She didn't just revel
in her creativity.
She owned it.
E. FOLEY: And she lived around
four and a half millennia ago.
So she is the most
ancient lady in our book.
B. COATES: So this is
a bit difficult to say,
but she was basically
the daughter
of King Sargon of
Akkhad, who appointed
her high priestess of the moon
god Nana and the goddess Inanna
in the holy city of Ur,
which is a bit of a mouthful.
But that is in southern Iraq.
So her father the
king was trying
to unite warring empire
states by putting
his daughter at the center,
in the holiest role.
She obviously took her
responsibility seriously,
and was good at it, because we
know she remained in the job
for over 40 years.
And she bagged herself
the claim in that 40
years of being history's
first recorded writer.
E. FOLEY: So the first recorded
writer, either man or woman,
in the planet's history.
B. COATES: Yeah, which I am
still staggered by, as a fact.
We know a lot about her
because of her creative legacy.
There's a body of work
that she left behind
in the hymns and poems
that she constructed,
and there's also a
fabulous stone engraving
called the disk of Enheduanna,
which depicts her taking
part in a ritual.
E. FOLEY: And she has a kind
of bald, crouching priest
at her feet.
And she has amazing
braids and a turban
and she's clearly a woman at
the top of her game in that.
B. COATES: Yeah.
So the poems and hymns
show us her character,
and her poems are
kind of amazing
because they have a
proper narrative arc,
and this is 4,5000 years ago.
There's one in particular that
talks about a political threat
she suffers, and she begs
her goddess for the power
to wreak her revenge.
By the end of the
poem she's back
in her proper position
as the holiest priestess.
There are loads of amazing
things in this poem.
E. FOLEY: And we
particularly like
the line, mistress of heaven
with the great pectoral jewels.
B. COATES: But
most astonishing is
her sort of sense of
authorship and ownership.
Again, she's the first recorded
person to use the first person.
She does it in these lines,
which says I am Enheduanna.
She says, I've given birth
to this song for you.
And I love that line,
because it gives
a sort of feminine kind
of slant to this idea
of the process of creativity.
And it's worth
remembering she was
doing all of this about
a millennium and a half
before Homer was tackling
"The Iliad" and "The Odyssey."
So she has, I think,
all the traits
that we associate with
really creative people.
She was original, inventive,
passionate, committed, fiery,
and all of that is doable.
I suppose the thing
to remember is
we don't have to all be in
the business of laying down
art that will
remain for centuries
to feel like we're
being creative.
We think it's to do with
everyday creativity,
and for me that
means just generally
asking more questions
about everything,
but it could also
be about trying
to be just more spontaneous
in your daily life,
disrupting your everyday
patterns in different ways.
E. FOLEY: So the
next lesson we have
comes from what seems like
a slightly unlikely place,
but covers an issue
that I think haunts
a lot of people for far
less significant reasons
than it might have haunted
famous concubine Nell Gwyn,
had she been that way inclined.
And what we learned
from Nell was
how to ride out shame
and embarrassment
and stop apologizing for
ourselves all the time.
So Eleanor Gwyn's origins
are not 100% clear,
but she was thought to
have been born in 1650.
She grew up in Covent Garden.
Her mother ran a brothel.
As a teenager she got
a job selling oranges
at what is now the Theatre
Royal in Drury Lane.
And those were very
exciting times in kind
of theatrical circles,
because the theaters had
been closed down for 11
years by Oliver Cornwell,
and the king had just recently
been restored to the throne.
And as part of
reopening the theaters
he also allowed women to act on
the stage for the first time,
because obviously in
Shakespeare's time and around
that only men could
act on the stage.
And this opened the
stage door for Nell,
who became the best
known and most celebrated
comic actress of her day.
And she was reviewed by Samuel
Pepys as pretty, witty Nell.
B. COATES: But then there
was a slightly ruder moment,
wasn't there, when he called
her a bold, merry slut.
E. FOLEY: Yes.
She starred in plays
by the likes of Dryden,
and she was admired by
people like Aphra Ben
and the Earl of Rochester.
And she had three
boyfriends called Charles,
and the most
significant of these
was the king, Charles II,
who ensured her lasting fame.
She met him in 1669,
and by the next year
she had given
birth to his child.
And Charles set her up
in a house in Pall Mall.
And one day he was
there at the house
visiting her and
the children, and he
heard Nell call their
oldest son by saying,
come here, you little bastard.
And that moved him to formally
acknowledge the boy as his son
and set him up as
an earl, so Nell
was quite shrewd in the way
that she handled the king.
She became one of his
most popular mistresses,
because she certainly
wasn't the only one.
Charles had about 14
illegitimate children
with pretty much about
the same number of women,
and Nelly became his kind of
bit of rough at this time,
but he also had a
posher mistress called
Louise de Keroualle
about the same time,
and she is now thought probably
to have been a French spy.
And Nell really
loved winding her up,
so she used to call
her the weeping willow
because she was quite
an emotional person.
B. COATES: But I
think there's evidence
that they liked hanging
out together, as well.
They played cards and
ate macaroons together.
E. FOLEY: They did, yes.
So it wasn't all handbags.
So Nell and Charles
kept their romance alive
until the king's death,
and on his deathbed
his famous last words
were to ask his brother,
the soon to be King James II,
not to let poor Nelly starve.
So James went along with
this, and he set Nelly up
very comfortably, and
she lived very happily
until she died quite young of
a stroke when she was just 38,
and she's buried in St.
Martin of the Fields church.
So what made her such
an excellent companion?
It was her shamelessness.
She didn't care
about going along
with respectable
feminine ideals,
and she wasn't ashamed
of the kind of odd role
that she had in society.
She seems to have
been a loyal friend.
She certainly seems to
have had a lot of fun.
She used to zoom around
in a sedan chair eating
oysters and macaroons.
She bought herself a silver
bed with the King's face carved
in it.
So she certainly made
the most of her position.
There was one time
where she was caught
in an angry crowd
in her carriage,
and the mob around
her were protesting,
because they thought that
Louise, who was very unpopular,
was in the carriage, and so
she leaned out the window
and shouted I'm the Protestant
whore, because Louise would've
been the Catholic one.
And the crowd then
dispersed in quite a cheery
way, because they were
entertained by Nell.
She was very entertaining.
So the best lesson
we learned from her
was not to be so easily
ashamed of setbacks,
and to put ourselves out
there despite the risk
of embarrassment, and to
make sure that we take
time to enjoy the good things
in life, like macaroons.
B. COATES: Yeah, absolutely.
So next we move on to
imposter syndrome, which
we think is the pernicious
underminer of talented people
everywhere.
So this is the idea that no
matter how brilliant you are,
no matter how
professional you are,
you believe the
compliments are lies
and you're probably only
one step away from being
handed your P45.
So how to deal with it?
It's difficult, but there's one
historical homemaker, Isabella
Beeton, who maybe ought to
have felt imposter syndrome,
but seems to have
laughed in the face of it
and got on with achieving stuff.
So what I think of
as Isabella Beeton
before we came to
research for this book,
I thought of this
matronly lady stalking
the halls of some country house
in her crinolines with a dish,
shouting at the servants.
But in fact-- and it is true
that her book, her famous book
of household management does
have some really deadly tips.
There's one where she says, when
a mistress is an early riser,
it's almost certain
that her house will
be orderly and well managed.
On the contrary, if she remain
in bed till a late hour,
then the servants are
likely to become sluggards.
E. FOLEY: We particularly
object to that one.
B. COATES: But actually,
she was this really young,
forward thinking entrepreneur.
She was a translator, she was a
journalist, she was an editor,
and the brilliant
thing about her
is that she was really
rubbish at cooking,
which was a surprise to me.
She was married to a publisher
and she wrote articles
for his magazine.
Her first contributions
were columns on cookery
and pickling and
preserving, and they
proved to be a massive hit,
despite the fact that she
couldn't cook.
E. FOLEY: Yeah, and she
actually even missed out
the flour in her
first cake recipe,
and she had to print an
apology the next week
because she had
missed out the flour.
B. COATES: The other
thing about her
is that she actually
stole most of her recipes.
So she'd been told by somebody
that culinary expertise took
decades to kind of gather,
and she decided she didn't
have time to waste doing that.
So she just nicked
them, basically,
and made very good use of the
lax copyright laws at the time.
But she did bring one
really original thing
to recipe making, which was
she sort of invented recipes,
actually.
So she was the person who
invented writing them in a list
so that you knew
which ingredients
you needed to have to hand
before you got on with it.
E. FOLEY: Yeah, she doesn't
specify measuring them out
into aspirational ceramics
like on "Bake Off,"
but we think she would have
approved of that, probably.
B. COATES: So and
her husband, ever
the opportunistic publisher,
realized he had hot property,
and he cooked up the idea
of "Mrs. Beeton's Book
of Household Management."
It was a massive bestseller,
and actually it's
still in print today,
nearly 150 years later.
What was the genius of
it was it wasn't just
the sort of 2,000
recipes that it contains.
It also had tips
on child rearing,
on boundary property
law, on menu planning.
So she was teaching this
generation of women around her
how to manage a household.
And so after her death--
she died-- again,
this is a thing I hadn't
realized, she died very young.
She was 28 when she died.
And she died after contracting
an infection after the birth
of her fourth child.
And basically it was
one of those moments
where after her death
her fame grew even more.
And you still find it on
people's cookery shelves today.
But what I love
about her is she's
this kind of dynamic
woman who built
this brand for
domestic goddessness,
but she was anything
but, really anything but.
So if you're suffering
from imposter syndrome,
as I quite often do,
I look to Isabella
and I think about the way
that she styled it out.
She sort of understood
that the path to success
lies in taking risks and not
being afraid of your mistakes,
and in fact realizing that our
flaws are no barrier to being
completely amazing.
E. FOLEY: So this
is our last woman.
And with Josephine
Baker we've looked
at the issue of having it all.
Now, in the media, having
it all is usually used
as a coded phrase to say
that women can't or shouldn't
have what men have.
And as a female, you're usually
expected if you're having it
all, then that means
you are effortlessly
combining an Instagrammable
home, a loving
passionate relationship
with your partner,
a stimulating and
high powered career,
and also you look amazing.
And actually the life of
celebrated dancer and singer
Josephine Baker actually
does tick all those boxes.
She sets a very high bar.
But she certainly didn't
achieve everything
that she achieved easily.
It wasn't given
to her on a plate.
She was born in poverty in St.
Louis in 1906, and as a child
she had to miss school
in order to go out
to work so that the family
could pay the bills.
And she started
dancing on the street
and in clubs when she
was a young teenager,
and despite people telling her
that she was too dark and too
skinny, she got really good.
She joined a dance troupe.
Her natural charm and
abilities led her to Broadway.
And it was from
there that she got
her really amazing
big break, which
is that the company that she
worked with when she was 19
decided to go on tour in Paris.
And 1920s Paris was fascinated
with the Harlem Renaissance,
with American jazz
and primitivism,
and Josephine's
dance number there,
which was called
the dance savage,
required her to dance
essentially only
wearing a feather skirt,
and audiences loved it.
Obviously this fetishization
of African culture
feels wrong today, but she
grabbed that opportunity
that she had.
And she used to drive
around in a Rolls-Royce
with her pet cheetah, Chiquita,
wearing lots of diamonds
and then she went on
to take on the act that
made her really
truly famous, which
is a sort of spirited
twerking number where she just
wears a belt made of
sparkling bananas.
B. COATES: And
from this point she
became a complete sensation.
She was the most highly
paid entertainer in Europe,
which is no mean feat for
a black American woman.
She had hundreds of
marriage proposals.
She was admired by Hemingway,
Picasso, Frida Kahlo, Collette.
E. FOLEY: And then she
went on to train really
hard to also become an
accomplished singer,
and she became the
first woman of color
in kind of major motion
pictures, as well.
Sadly, when she returned
on a tour to the US,
her home country was
not ready to accept
a beautiful, rich, talented
black woman in this way,
and she met with
quite racist reviews.
And so when she came back to
France the next year in 1937,
she became a French citizen.
And her devotion to her new
country was really passionate.
When World War II started, she
worked with the resistance,
and she actually used to
smuggle secrets around
in her sheet music
in her underwear,
because she was able to
travel as an entertainer
in a particular way that was
helpful to the resistance.
And after the war she was
presented with many honors
for her service.
One of the things I loved
when I was researching her
is that if you find clips
of her speaking voice
it's completely heavenly
and extraordinary,
but there are also
amazing photos
of her receiving her medals
from the French government
with her children,
and her children
were another kind of
key part of her story.
So after distressing experiences
trying to have a baby,
she ended up adopting
12 different children
from different countries,
different races and religions.
And besides her
wish to be a mother,
she also had a political
purpose in this
in that she wanted to build
a rainbow tribe in order
to prove that people
from diverse backgrounds
could get along.
B. COATES: Yes, she
made her chateau
into a sort of theme park
where people could come and see
her children and see the
rainbow tribe together,
which is a good
intention, but must
have been a very weird
experience to have as a child.
E. FOLEY: Very strange.
Yeah.
But linked to this project of
hers, she also in the '50s,
became active in the Civil
Rights Movement in the US.
She refused to play to
segregated audiences in Las
Vegas, and there was a famous
incident in the Stork Club
in Manhattan, where they
refused to serve her
and she kicked off a huge
fuss, and this got her
in a lot of trouble.
She was labeled as a
commie troublemaker.
She was investigated by
the FBI because of it.
B. COATES: And I suppose
it's that thing that,
linked to today, it's sort of
depressing that a woman kicking
up a fuss, speaking her mind
about a perceived injustice
is still something
that even now we see
is met with
disproportionate criticism.
But there was a happy outcome to
the Stork Club incident, which
is that she formed a lasting
friendship with Grace
Kelly, who happened to
be there and walked out
at the same time.
And that's something we
found again and again
through our book,
it's these instances
where women support other
women and good stuff
comes out of that.
E. FOLEY: Yeah, because even
later when Josephine actually--
the cost of running the kind
of amazing chateau theme park
sent her bankrupt,
Princess Grace gave her
a house in Monaco so that
she could look after her.
And then it was only in
1973 that Josephine finally
got the applause she wanted
from the United States
when she did a performance
at Carnegie Hall, which was
kind of rapturously received.
And not long after that she did
another big grand performance
in Paris to celebrate the first
anniversary of her dancing
there.
And it was only a few
days later that she died.
And she was found
dead in her bed
with her amazing reviews
all scattered around her.
20,000 people lined the
streets for her funeral,
and she was buried with
full military honors.
B. COATES: So did she have it
all, though, is the question?
E. FOLEY: I mean, when
you look at her rags
to riches tale and her
professional excellence,
and the lovely pictures of
our cute kids in the castle,
it looks like it, but
she took a lot of fire
from people who saw her
as an upstart, people who
saw her four failed
marriages, thought
she was a bizarre mother,
a political loose cannon,
obviously she went bankrupt.
Now she's recognized as the
unique and powerful performer
that she is, and as a brave war
hero, civil rights activist,
and a style icon.
B. COATES: Yeah, there are
these great pictures of her
in her huge sunglasses
in late life.
She's wonderful.
E. FOLEY: And her
influence endures.
She's inspired lots of
people, including Beyonc.
Most of us would be
immensely proud to have
anything near the kind of
life that Josephine had.
But she did work
unbelievably hard to get it,
and she suffered
a lot of setbacks.
I'm sure at various
points she didn't
know that the end result would
be this incredible career.
So it was very liberating for
us to realize that having it
all means only going for what
you want on your own terms
to the best of your
particular abilities,
and accepting that things
will always keep changing,
and that is certainly
something that Josephine did.
B. COATES: So that's it.
That's our 10, our 10
women from the past
who we believe can help
our present in really
tangible, concrete ways.
We have there a queen, an
inventor, a spy, a warrior,
a poet, an explorer, a
priestess, a concubine, a cook,
and a dancer--
all much more exciting jobs
than most of us can have.
But all these women
excelled at what
they put their energies
into, and all of them
left their mark.
And they certainly raised
our sense of what's possible,
and they raised our
spirits as well.
E. FOLEY: We had a really
joyful time writing the book
and working with the
illustrator, Bijou Karman,
whose work you've
seen behind us today.
And we hope that you and perhaps
aunties, sisters, you know,
daughters enjoy it, and it
gives you an amusing few hours
and solves all of your problems.
B. COATES: Thank you
so much for having us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So we have
time for some questions
if anyone has any.
AUDIENCE: How did you
go about your research
and deciding who
would be in the book?
B. COATES: Yeah, so the decision
making was one of the hardest
but also one of the
most fun bits of it.
We actually have a list
of about 290 other women,
and it's called spare ladies.
It's a document that we have.
E. FOLEY: Turns out women have
been doing really great things
for a really long time.
B. COATES: So we came up with
a list of modern dilemmas
that we thought were
worth answering,
and then we came up
with a list of women,
and we were really clear
that we wanted the women
to be representative of all
different countries, but also
different disciplines.
So we both work in the
publishing industry,
so our natural instinct
was to go with lots
of writers and artists.
But in fact, we wanted
scientists in there
and explorers and sportswomen
and all those other facets.
And then just a quick
look at a woman's life
and you'd immediately
see the little point that
answered the modern dilemma, and
that was the springboard for us
to then go off and
research them more fully.
So there's definitely people
we regret leaving out.
Marie Curie's not in there.
Maya Angelou.
I feel bad about her.
E. FOLEY: You feel bad
about Mary, Queen of Scots.
B. COATES: I do you feel bad
But yeah, maybe for volume two.
AUDIENCE: What inspired
you on this subject?
I was going to ask what do you
do, but you work in publishing,
but why did you
pick this subject?
B. COATES: So it genuinely
came from watching
the women's marches post
the election in America.
We were really inspired
by all those placards
about nasty women,
and the way that women
were kind of reclaiming it from
an insult into a positive term.
So we originally thought of it
as a book celebrating the kind
of nasty women of the past.
And a lot of the
women in our book
are sort of difficult
and complex,
and that was something else
we wanted to highlight.
They're not perfect,
any of these women.
They're sort of bad mothers.
E. FOLEY: Yeah, alcoholics.
Bad girlfriends.
B. COATES: Exactly.
And we really wanted to
show that these aren't
kind of bastions of perfection.
But then we also,
as we said, wanted
to take it a step
further and see
is there a way that
these amazing nasty women
from the past can help
us with modern dilemmas.
So that was where it came from.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a favorite?
E. FOLEY: Yeah, Josephine's
one of my favorites.
B. COATES: And I think
Isabella Beeton is one of mine.
But I do love Sappho, as well.
You can't-- it was a very joyful
experience to write this book,
and they all were genuinely--
E. FOLEY: Mae West is
really good too, actually.
B. COATES: Yeah, she's great.
And Frida Kahlo's
amazing as well.
E. FOLEY: That's the thing, Once
we start it's very difficult.
AUDIENCE: Do you
get quoted on that?
AUDIENCE: There's a children's
book you might have heard of,
"Good Night Stories
for Rebel Girls"
which is doing sort of
a fairly similar thing.
What do you think is different
about what you're going for?
E. FOLEY: So yeah, I
think the main thing
is that ours is for a
kind of an older audience.
So we have swearing in our book.
And I love--
"Good Night Stories"
is a brilliant book,
and my children read it, and
your children read it at night,
but the premise of that is to
present these women's stories
as fairy tales.
And in a way, what
we wanted to do
was quite different to that
in that we are depicting them
warts and all, and we are
looking at adult problems
in relation to their lives.
So I mean that book is a
gorgeous and wonderful book,
and we sort of
hope this is a kind
of slightly older sister to it.
B. COATES: Yeah, that's
a good way of putting it.
But yeah, we have some
really difficult women in it.
So Coco Chanel, who I think is
also in "Good Night Stories,"
and what they
don't talk about is
her sort of Nazi
sympathizing past
as well, because obviously--
E. FOLEY: It's for children.
B. COATES: But we do
confront that in the book.
And then another figure who
we really hemmed and hawed
over putting in there was
Marie Stopes, because she
held some really dodgy kind
of world views at the time.
But again, that was
really intentional.
We thought long and
hard about that.
We wanted difficult
women in there as well.
We didn't want to sugar coat it.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious,
what is the most poignant lesson
that you each have
taken away from all
the various chapter problems?
E. FOLEY: I mean, I
think for me it really
is this idea of women
helping other women,
because that's something that we
had-- and actually to be fair,
also there are
lots of great dads
and brothers and
husbands in this book who
are really instrumental
in allowing these women,
or helping these women
achieve what they achieved.
B. COATES: Yeah,
there's a lot of fathers
who refused to accept that
their daughters couldn't have
a decent education, so they
would educate them privately
or find other ways to kind
of instill education in them.
And that was very
moving, wasn't it?
E. FOLEY: It was.
That they had to
step outside of what
was supposed to be
allowed for girls,
and the father
supported them in that.
But we have-- so the Princess
Grace and Josephine one's
something that we love, but also
when we talk about the tennis
player Althea
Gibson, and she has
an amazing kind of
mentor relationship
with women who had helped her.
B. COATES: So she was
like the first black woman
to win Wimbledon in
the '50s, and just it
was really moving that there are
certain moments during her life
where just women swooped
in and really helped her.
So one of the white
champions at the time
wrote this open letter to a
magazine to say come on guys,
why don't we let her into
the Lawn Tennis Association?
And that was a great moment.
And then later in
her life when she'd
sort of fallen afoul of the
American health care system,
again, another woman swooped
in and raised a load of money
to pay for her health care.
So that was really
moving, that sense
of women helping each other.
AUDIENCE: You say
that you're very
intentional in distributing
through different regions,
times in history,
but you also say
that you have 290 spare women.
Is there any particular
time in history or region
that stands out for having a
lot of women in that period?
B. COATES: I mean, I think
what we tried not to do,
because ultimately
what you do end up
with when you look
at these lists
is quite a lot of
Victorian white women.
E. FOLEY: Yes, that's
where the records are.
B. COATES: That's
That seems to be
where women suddenly
did start to change the world.
E. FOLEY: And rich
Victorian white women.
B. COATES: Very wealthy
E. FOLEY: So that's
why there are
queens in all of these books.
Because there's loads of
documentation about them,
so obviously it makes
the research richer.
B. COATES: Yeah.
But we were clear that we
didn't want to do that.
We wanted to go to slightly
unusual places in the world
and also in history and see
what lessons you could draw.
E. FOLEY: Because
there were women
we discovered for the first
time in writing the book,
and that's something
that we wanted to do,
was find out about people
that we'd never heard of.
And so we have
quite a few of them,
as well as having
the big famous ones.
B. COATES: Thank
you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]